I'd like you to do two things firstly
think about the two most loved ones in
your life right now
great next I'd like you to rank them on
a scale of 1 to 10 this scale is how
much you share yourself with them your
innermost thoughts and your emotions one
being you share nothing 10 being that
you're a complete open book cool it
seems that we all have it
so hold at the end of a slow key note
and we'll come back to that
my lucky note today is about
relationships and connections and about
what holds us back from them see to me a
real relationship is one way you share
yourself with your loved ones you share
your innermost thoughts you share your
emotions in aid and service of a better
relationship but I don't think we do
that enough I don't think we have the
strongest Asian ships we could and the
silent enemy here is our own
misperceptions what are misperceptions
well if I'm trying to share myself I
might be worried about protecting
someone protecting them from what my
innermost thoughts and emotions are I
might be worried about changing the
image they have in their head of me or
worst of all breaking the relationship
because we're scared of sharing
ourselves and I notice because I do this
every single day and it's something I'm
trying not to do see I overweight the
risks I worry about protecting people I
worry about losing them and as such I
don't share the risk I could have share
those risks and
so because I don't do it enough I
underweight the benefits and I don't do
it again and I don't want you to make
the same mistake with your close loved
ones I'm gonna tell you a few stories
where I have closed myself off because
of my own misperceptions and hopefully
you can open up then from there I lost
my father when I was six years old he
went missing on a business trip and we
never heard from him again and my family
went into chaos
those sadness there was anger and some
depression as well and from age of six
13 I was told nothing it took two when I
was 13 and I was totally oblivious
before that point and I'm playing in the
park my uncle and his two and his two
net two sons my cousins and I hear one
my cousin's shout dad dad pass the ball
and something just dropped and I asked
myself a question he has a dad where is
my dad and misperceptions started
filling my head was it my fault my dad
had disappeared
what were they not telling me what was a
great secret I'd been a happy kid
beforehand I'd run straight home from
school and I would go to my family and
tell him how my day was this changed I
ran straight to my room every single day
for the next year I'd closed myself off
from my family I delved myself into my
books and I got great grades which was
which I loved before
but I got validation from my grades and
not who I truly was inside it took six
months of counseling get past this six
months counselling to get over the grief
but moreover realize that I was holding
misperceptions in my own head my family
had lost a husband an uncle and a son
how could they tell a six or thirteen
year old boy but your father isn't
coming back because that would mean
accepting it for themselves I realized
this means a misperception I was wrong
so I became a happier kid from now I
opened up my family I used to run to
them tell them how my day was cuz I know
it was my own misperception but my
misperception had closed me off for a
year and a half - my family had lots of
time with them
now the next story is a teenage rite of
passage it's the one we all know all too
well and it's telling your parents
you've been on a date it's that kind of
story I see you nervous chuckle around
the room yep to give you some backstory
my mother had been on four dates my
father and they decided to get married
very traditional Indian society so what
I fought for my mother what she wanted
for me was I'm go to a good high school
get great University get good internship
get great grad your job you can see what
is going go to great graduate program
Stanford MBA will do
find wife and have a very good life big
box so I'm 18 and back home from college
it's the first time I'm back and I've
been on Davis wonderful girl and for a
week or so I've been debating do I tell
my mother week later I'm in a kitchen
cooking with her and I finally decide to
break the news to her but I'm worried
what's she gonna think of me is she
doing less of me do you think I'm not
traditional but I say anyway cooking
mushrooms I say mom so I've kind of met
a girl oh you met a girl
what do you mean met a girl oh we've
been on a few dates Oh have you kissed
yet and at this point my heart is going
boom boom boom
my misperceptions are filling my head
I'm just thinking oh god what do I do
now advice I'd tell her I say yes but
very nervously and her reaction is one
that I never could have imagined
anymore
at this moment I realized my miss
deceptions were all gone she didn't want
me to follow traditional path she was
happy and excited for me and now I'm
very open with my mother about my
relationships if anything she's too
involved now but that's a story for
another day my final story is about
gangs I know my father better now as you
recall my father went missing when I was
six and I have four memories of him
that's four memories of someone who's
50% of my DNA that's crazy and last year
when I was doing a talk of the GSB I
realized this but the reason I hadn't
asked my family since I was six was
because of the fact that I fought they
need to be protected it was a
misperception yes they were hurting they
had gone through the strife if I open
this kind of worms up then I would be
causing a family struggle so I had held
back but I realized I just had to know
for memories was not enough for me so I
took my uncle in for the cold sitting
room two Christmases ago we had one we
have a very jovial relationship so he
knew something was up he goes Jay this
seems pretty serious what's going on and
now my misperceptions are playing am I
gonna hurt him
am I gonna cause family struggles and
he's a motion stop bubbling up within me
and before I know I'm saying I go what
the hell I know absolutely nothing at
all what the hell's going on I know for
memories I even told me anything I know
you're hurting
let me know his face his jaw is dropping
his face is getting whiter and whiter
and my misperceptions are playing oh god
what the hell have I just done but his
response
again why play my misperceptions I can't
believe we haven't talked about this
sooner I had no idea why you've never
asked me and I know but we needed to
have this discussion misperceptions
wiped my uncle didn't need to be
protected this wasn't gonna cause some
family struggle or strife but I my own
misperceptions had held back knowing
about my father since I was six I could
have known 19 years ago about my father
yet my own misperceptions has held me
back from finding out about 50% on my
DNA that's crazy and I don't want you to
make the same mistake but I did so I'll
ask you this go back so there's two
people at the start this low-key no but
you had in your head your two loved ones
and this weekend ask yourself what
misperceptions are you holding about
those two loved ones that are holding
you from fully sharing yourself and
having a strong and great relationship
with them and then just go yeah take
that risk because if those two loved
ones aren't worth at risk then who is
thank you